هل تريد سانجاي الوصول إلى سؤال المشاهد
الذي أعتقد أنه سؤال
جيد حقًا ، هذا هو الذقن الذي قد يسأله
يبدو أننا سنكون مطالبين بأخذ
لقاح الأنفلونزا ونشتهي في
الأشهر القليلة القادمة هل هناك طلب معين
يجب علينا
تناولهم في حال تناولنا الإنفلونزا قبل الإصابة بالفيروس أو هل يهم متى
وكيف نتناولهم ، ثم يمكنك أيضًا
إخبارنا متى
يجب أن نتناول لقاح الإنفلونزا في حال كنا نتناوله في
وقت أبكر مما قد نفعله عادةً
بشكل صحيح.  قد
لا يكون الأمر مهمًا ولكنه مهم
ولهذا السبب ربما
تطرح السؤال في البداية عندما خرج لقاح الطمع ،
كان التوجيه
هو الانتظار 14 يومًا على الأقل قبل أن
تحصل على لقاح آخر وجزء منه  من ذلك
لمجرد أنهم ما زالوا
يكتشفون بالضبط نوع الآثار الجانبية
التي قد يعاني منها الأشخاص بعد اللقطة
وكانوا يلعبونها بأمان الآن بعد أن أصبح
لديهم كل هذه البيانات التي يقولون إنه
لا يهم حتى أنه يمكنك الحصول
على اللقطات  نفس اليوم  إذا كنت ترغب
في الحصول عليها في وقت واحد في
مواقع حقن مختلفة حتى تعرف ما إذا
كنت تحصل عليها في كلا الذراعين ، فقد يكون
لديك ذراعا مؤلمان ، لذا ضع ذلك في
الاعتبار ولكن لا يهم حقًا
بقدر ما يتعلق بلقاح الأنفلونزا  أنت
تعلم أننا نتحدث عن
هذا النوع من الضربة المزدوجة
المحتملة منك تعرف كل هذه
الفيروسات التنفسية المختلفة وتطمح في
نفس الوقت لذلك يوصون
بالحصول على لقاح الأنفلونزا في غضون الأسابيع القليلة المقبلة
أه أنت ليس كذلك عادةً  هناك
مشكلة في الحصول على لقاح الإنفلونزا مبكرًا ، فالمشكلة
الوحيدة هي أنك إذا بدأت في رؤية
اندفاعات كبيرة من الإنفلونزا في
يناير فبراير ، وهو نوع من الإطار الزمني الذي
تعرفه أنك تريد التأكد من أنك
محمي جيدًا في تلك المرحلة
وكذلك في  في الأسابيع القليلة المقبلة ،
أوصي بالحصول على لقاح الإنفلونزا ،
وسنرى عن المعززات التي سنراها
حول المعززات التي تعرفها الأسبوع المقبل
سيكون أسبوعًا كبيرًا فيما يتعلق بـ FDA
و cdc وسنرى ما
يوصون به رسميًا وأنا أعلم  هناك الكثير س  إذا كانت هناك أخبار
حول هذا الأمر ، لكنك تعلم أننا سننتظر فقط
ونرى ما سيقولونه من حيث الطريقة
التي يوصون بها بذلك